of the stars from K-pop band BTS  reported for boot camp this morning in  South Korea Jin is starting 18 months of  military service mandatory for all  able-bodied South Korean men aged 18 to  28 the heartthrob posted this selfie  let's see the uh he got a little haircut  look at his selfie on social media  Sunday revealing his freshly shaved head  high and tight they call it  if you said it's quote cuter than I  thought it looks great it looks good  very cute uh jyn is the oldest member of  BTS at age 30. officials say he will  undergo a physically demanding five-week  basic training course before he's  assigned to a military unit the six  other BTS members are expected to  fulfill their draft obligations based on  their own timelines the group plans to  reconvene in 2025 after the performers  complete their service